you know they say um
prison was my saving grace but then on
the flip side of that i look at
well what part does rehabs play in all
of this
you know if i don't take a look at that
aspect
then people won't understand or realize
how
it took up to 30 attempts
for me to finally get it get it
so i like to integrate on um
life in rehabs you know life and trying
to get my [ __ ] together life and trying
to get my life
in some kind of order trying to get from
chaos to to normalcy and all the
countless vein attempts in between so um
i like to start from you know
what was it what how it was sold to me
you know
it was told to me that you know hey look
man
when it gets tough on the streets when
it gets bad you want to check out
you don't have to take your ass to
prison you can go to rehab
you know it's less dress you know and
you got more available to you right
i said okay that was so when the seed
was planted to me
it was it was planted to me like i think
after my fourth trip to prison man when
i came home
and i was i ended up right back where i
started off at
and there's shape real fast so um
now i like that rehab as an adventure
you know because
i'm not going home away from home but
i'm still on the streets i'm still in
the
in the in the environment you know and
um
i never wanted to do a program close to
where i lived i wanted to be
out like where where the quote-unquote
where the money was
because like santa monica west hollywood
san fernando valley there's more money
so for someone like me there'd be more
opportunity
or so i thought not knowing
that rehabs are set up just like
say the present setting they only can
give you so much
and first and foremost rehabs are
a business don't get it twisted so
whatever you don't put into it
it's just your ass don't get up out of
it and for me i never figured
i never forget being in the first rehab
man and it was like 30 of us in a room
they said out of 30 of you
only three percent are going to make it
so out of 30 that's only three you guys
so look next look to your neighbor
because you might not see them again
before this is all over so i look to my
left man
excuse me i look to my right then i look
to my left and i said i know they ain't
talking about me
and lord behold i wasn't one of the
three percent man that made it
no i didn't i didn't see
the importance in that in that in that
statement right there
for the simple fact that i had no idea
what i was going into going into rehab i
had no idea
how bad the disease was on me that
cracked [ __ ] cocaine i didn't
know how bad of a hold of a grip it had
on me
so when i went into the first rehab i i
didn't even have all the courage i left
the courage i left the strip
because that [ __ ] had a hold of me and
to be honest with you i wasn't even
finished with smoking that crack
now going to rehab i'm okay
going into it i was like okay i need
help you know i'm good but
there's many factors that could have
played a reason in that
i remember my second third fourth fifth
trip to rehab
you know oh i'm gonna do this for my
mama
this is this is for my mama for all the
time she's been there for me and
supported me and loved me and all that
[ __ ]
go for her
become the compliant client in there do
everything i'm supposed to do jump
through the [ __ ] hoops do
everything i'm supposed to do
get over it end up right back up right
back where i was in words
okay i'm gonna do it this time for for
my nephew christopher
cause i wasn't there for his childhood
growing up so this is for you kid
i'm gonna do this for my my nephew
isaiah oh now
i'm gonna do this for my sister tracy
because she always loved and supported
me her baby brother
you know what i'm gonna do this one for
todd to show him that i am somebody that
i am capable
and the last one i just blew my
[ __ ] mind oh this is for god
who had his hand on me the whole
[ __ ] time i've been in and out
back and forth to prison off and on that
[ __ ] crap
for having his hand over me and having a
grace of mercy oh this for you god i got
you
yeah right
i went in programs half-heartedly
because truth be told how can i go into
rehab
and then do a session on talking or
doing a one-on-one with my counselor and
say straight up man i had a dream the
night before men who wanted to smoke a
ton of crack cocaine man
and damn they left this [ __ ] to
go i'm gonna be in a rehab until my
counselor that on the one-on-one
how it still had a hold on my ass so i
didn't want to let me go and i wasn't
ready for it to let me go
cause i wasn't tired man i wasn't to the
point man where i just fully surrendered
so i'm coming up with all these excuses
all these disguises all these
different ways to maneuver you know
instead of just
really doing it for me
i remember in between say the seventh
and the
fifteenth rehab every time i go
it's like boy this girl on campus
fall in love get married live happily
ever after it seemed like from the
back then when i was going to say i was
going to rehabs all through the 90s
so it was like kind of a it was cold
back then to be in rehab
you know to have the um i remember going
to a rehab and
all the fellas was was real nice and
sharp and clean and after little
rings and little watching this and that
and i had nothing
so my thing was how fast can i
accumulate
the outside things and say i go to a six
month program
now i only go i show up with a trash bag
with a few belongings
within six months i'll leave with a nice
watch
maybe a tree maybe a ring maybe a nice
little necklace
two three trash bags full of pants
shirts all the stuff that accumulator
now i think i'm the man but i say from
the seventh to about this
20th rehab that was my thing that was my
mode of operation
going to the [ __ ] with nothing
but just with the clothes on my back
and try to leave out with as much as i
can with a truck
truck full load of stuff that i
accumulated
hey man you need this hey you gonna use
that hey can i get you hey
hustling caught myself fussing trying to
get back on my feet
talking about oh i'm i'm trying to get
the get back
man please it wasn't no get back
i wasn't there to get my [ __ ] together i
was there to accumulate some stuff
that's all
i mean i put forth an attempt of course
a half-hearted ass attempt
because every time i go up to the rehab
i meet her
oh she's gonna make everything all right
oh yeah we gonna do this [ __ ] together
we gonna combine our strengths together
and ain't nothing that can take us down
[ __ ] as soon as i get to the program
i see her she see me she smiles she
wink here we go again man i don't give a
[ __ ] about
my what problem i don't have no problems
[ __ ] man hey girl what's your name hey
how long have you been here
hey you wanna do and lo and behold
it ain't about me no more being in rehab
it's about her
her needs her wants how can i deal with
her how can i take care of her how can i
meet her needs how can i
how can i meet her standards while
trying to navigate uh baby no i wasn't
that bad on the streets
now i'm lying she don't know nothing
about me but what i tell her so i'm
trying to paint this picture
of how i ended up in here but i'm not
that bad do i look bad girl oh hell no
see i told you i wasn't that bad as most
viewers out there on that stuff
then i kind of changed the picture or
what was your own baby on this oh
alcohol marijuana i don't do that crack
stuff
cocaine no no not me please do it look
like a crackhead
cold game that i played in rehab
rehabs over the years off and on
i went to rehabs man when i was just
really [ __ ] tired of just being tired
[ __ ] feet is aching and hurting
[ __ ] lips is burning swollen from the
[ __ ] pipe being
being like this and beginning like this
in the end burning [ __ ] off my lips my
fingers
can't reflect the blick lighter
we're [ __ ] having eight nine 10 days
had a cup of water a cup of noodle or
nothing man not even bathed
that's when i need to rehab that's when
the doors are open up for me
and then i have to go into the go to the
detox
go in there for like four or five days
sleep in a cocaine coma
that means i'm as soon as i close my
eyes i'm not waking up for three four
five days
and then once i get about the cocaine
slumber and then i still go
man i'm glad that part is over the hard
part is over now i want to eat up every
[ __ ] thing and and drink up
everything
like i try to smoke up everything on the
streets man and drink about alcohol
you know just the roads reverse
you know so now i get off the cocaine
slumber so i'm eating up i'm going
to eat everything i can you know eating
up all the cereal the milk the water all
that kind of stuff man
and now he said okay eric um these are
the options we have for you we have
these programs
hey man it has to be co-ed
why does it have to be co-ed why does
women have to be a part of the equation
because i've been in and out of prison
all these years man i'm not trying to be
on the streets man
and dealing with a whole bunch of [ __ ]
heads i did that [ __ ] in prison
i got 19 trips in between these 30
rehabs man
[ __ ] i want to be on the streets and
just dealing with me and for i can do
that [ __ ] in prison
on the streets man i want the like i
said before
i don't i don't want to be around all
men i i'm sorry i can't handle i can't
deal with that
because it makes me feel like i'm in
prison again
oh i had to get the gap i just didn't
know i was fooling myself
yeah it worked okay yeah okay
okay yeah we got this place called this
place out here called acting
man i get out there it's in the middle
of the wilderness you got cabins and all
that kind of stuff man you got the gym
out there man i'm in heaven
got my ass out there worked in the
kitchen became a
fitness instructor up in there man and
i like that one so much i went five
times
in a row back to back to back to back to
back the [ __ ] back
and all five times i was in a
relationship
on the campus thinking i'm hips looking
cool thinking i'm doing something
you know but all the while i was there
and all the times that i was there those
five times all i did was diverting the
tension off of me and putting it on her
or putting it on the gym or putting it
on the kitchen where the [ __ ] else i was
being a service actor because i wasn't
being a service to myself
i was i was helping everything and
everybody outside of me
so i wouldn't have to deal with my
[ __ ] soul wouldn't have to look
at me
man if i had to go all the way back from
the beginning
leading up to when i first got into the
rehab man i wasn't not know what to say
about this here
man now about my track record
man you better not show me a real
picture i'll kill you
you know because man i did damage man i
did horn man to
to myself and to everybody that came in
contact with me man
and i did a lot of robbing i did a lot
of stealing did a lot of stuff man
behind the name of that crack cocaine
man
it wasn't a [ __ ] thing funny
about getting that money by any means
necessary
ask somebody
towards the end of my campaign man of
doing this this rehab marathon kind of
thing man because
i prided myself on i said okay i've been
to to
to three different rehabs nine times you
know
i remember i was a part of the um back
in the days at the mary lynn foundation
so
i did the [ __ ] arena b the memory the
royal palms
two of them were co-ed one was all male
so i did the the co-eds like four times
a piece so i did
these two programs eight times eight
different times
four times in this [ __ ] four
times in this one all eight times i was
in relationship
i said let me try the last one the
all-male program part of it
and see what that if that helped when i
go to the
to the to the all-male facility and
ended up climbing down the fire escape
i think after maybe three days i was
there because i got tired of looking off
the [ __ ] window across the
street looking at the pipes at the bus
at the [ __ ] phone booth uh do his
thing he was
serving man let me go down and see if
this [ __ ] working with
so instead of being like the average joe
going down the stairs right man i climb
out the window down the fire escape
took mass across the street cop brought
my ass back to my room
into mr smoke man and um
once i started i couldn't stop and
call myself going downstairs for um
for dinner so i started in the afternoon
i think around 8 10 or 11 in the
afternoon
and then was at 4 35 5 o'clock so 5
o'clock come around i'm going downstairs
tweaked off my [ __ ] mind
eyes as big as golf balls and put me to
the side here man we need to test you no
you don't
no you don't i'm dirty man i surrender
how the [ __ ] you end up getting loaded
i don't know you tell me my your guess
is good as mine [ __ ]
you the counselor don't you have the
answer
how the [ __ ] i'm i have no idea how i
end up getting loaded in rehab this
ain't the first one it's probably gonna
be the last one
i'm trying to come up with a viable
answer to this [ __ ] cause i really i
have no clue
on how i go to get some [ __ ]
help and then and then while i'm at the
place getting help
i end up getting loaded man of getting
the ends the ends to the means to get
loaded i don't know how it happens man
it seems like something just takes over
my mind i'm here one minute the next
minute of somebody else is some kind of
entity takes over
and it just has me going out there and
god
it's like magic i still can't get that
trick
i never understood how they put the
bunny out the the the rabbit out the
head
and i see i've seen it a thousand times
it's like my experiences in rehab
i know some [ __ ] and i understand some
things
but for the life of me for me to be in
and getting some help
and then become helpless
i just never got that part of it
i call on god please god you got to show
me something you got to do something man
you know and um finally man i think
towards the 30th trip man my 30th
tripping uh
going to my um i got to see it man to my
my saving grace man because rehab was a
part of my saving grace man because if
it wasn't for rehab i probably would end
up dead man
a lot quicker than being in prison you
know because
i have to admit even though i was in
relationships
even though sometimes i went for other
people
but i always went for the right reasons
now in the beginning
i didn't have see i the grip of cocaine
was so strong on me i didn't know the
power
still had a hold over me even while i
was in rehab
and so while i'm in in it to say the
first 10 rehabs while i'm in there
the the hole that crack cocaine was so
strong i didn't know it still had that
pull on me and it was still
it was still it was like the puppet
master so it was still pulling all the
strings even while i was there trying to
get my [ __ ] together my life together
it was pulling the strings it was
running the show i didn't know that at
the time because i had no idea
now after about 15 20 trips
and really putting forth an effort i
guess i start the soul searching i start
self realization and some things start
coming up from from way
deep inside man that that i haven't been
able to take a look at
for the for the past say 30 years
i'm gonna say one thing and i'm gonna
end it on this snow because this is this
is real personal
to me
my last program man my 30th month
i was asleep and something woke me up
and it was
a dream of my father and me and my
father smoking
crack in a mother
in a garage years ago man and i think i
was
11 or 12. and
it just came up all of a sudden because
i always wondered
what was my first experiences what was
my favorite experience on crack and with
who
and i thought it was with the
neighborhood kids i thought my cousin
my first experience with crack cocaine
was what my dad
and it took the 30th [ __ ] trip
to rehab
for it to come up and i was thinking to
myself
i remember clearly now when it happened
and i remember after we we're leaving
we're leaving the garage we get in the
car
he says hey don't don't tell your moms
just don't say nothing about this
experience when i got you pop something
good you know
hit pimp ray don't worry about nothing
but i remember this
just feeling i had in my stomach man it
was because
i wanted more and i know i couldn't
answer for no more hey pops can you give
me
it was over you know he let me hit it i
think about four times man
but as you're believing that [ __ ] was
only so tough
i couldn't even tell him hey pops
whatever this feeling is it's just us
it's consuming me
and i want more
you know what after he dropped me back
off at my mother's house
i birthed that [ __ ] so [ __ ]
deep
that when i think i was 15 or 16 and
that [ __ ] hit the neighborhood and it
came back around
and i started doing the primos thinking
that was my first
my first time okay this is this is it
for me my first trial
my first experience at doing this [ __ ]
promos
that wasn't it it was five years prior
to that with my father but i had
their very that [ __ ] so deep he couldn't
even come up
to show me how i feel way back then to
stop me from
moving forward with the primos
they killed me for 30 something
[ __ ] years that one experience
if i just couldn't it just but it was so
deep my birthday
man if i would have died or got hurt out
there you know i would have take that
[ __ ] to the grave with me
that's how deep it was man and it's only
one person i shared that with i shared
that with my mama
told my mama my first experience with
that [ __ ]
but look how many trips it took to rehab
for me to get to that place
so it helps it helped me
and it freed me from
this lie of the first time i ever did it
was with the primos man in the
neighborhood with the fellas
that's a damn lie
man now moving forward
all i have to do is keep being
open-minded to these
to these self-realizations whenever they
come i don't give a [ __ ] if it takes 20
more years for something else to come up
that'll help me set my feet firmer on on
steady ground on solid ground
whatever it takes man i don't care
whatever [ __ ] that i'm very deep that i
forgot about
for the past thousand years i hope that
[ __ ] come up so i could be set free a
little bit at a time so i could keep on
putting one foot
in front of the other wasn't about the
rehabs it was always about me
having the courage having the strength
having the fortitude
the aptitude to to really want to to
to put all the cars on the table hell no
not in the beginning
took about 25 trips to rehab before i
finally started to see that i had to put
something up
in order to get something in return [ __ ]
i'm in rehab and i'm going through the
motions but i'm not really putting forth
the serious effort
then i wonder why i ended back up on the
[ __ ] side of the freeway off
ramp it seemed like every time i
take a hit off the pipe blow the smoke
out i see prison prison bars
and somewhere in the smoke two three
weeks i'm in prison
i'll leave rehab leave that [ __ ]
take a hit off the pipe blow the smoke
off
i see myself in the side of some
[ __ ] freeway y'all from if i'm
way out there
on in in san fernando valley off the
[ __ ] uh
off the the one-on-one freeway off of uh
oh my god man on the side of a freeway
off ramp i said i can't believe this
[ __ ]
now i'm talking about three months later
after i left the rehab how the [ __ ] to
get way out here
on the side of for real for real on the
side of the freeway off rim
but that's what the smoke showed me from
the hit from the pipe
prior to that so i got managed to scare
me to take a hit off the pipe once i
left different rehabs because
whatever i saw within the midst of the
smoke i knew that [ __ ] was coming true
and it was nothing i could do to stop it
i couldn't change it
and that's the power that being
and that's what i was in under the grips
on the man
so
i thank god for the rehabs i think god
for all the time said
that i didn't have the courage man that
but i just kept on going back to kept on
going back because
even though i didn't know what was going
to happen i didn't know what i was to
expect
and even in the times that i knew what i
was getting into man what i was going
for even if it was the wrong motives man
then at least i knew that i had a chance
at something
maybe that love at the time man when i
met her never thought i could meet her
we can come together and live happily
ever after that's what i thought at the
time
or it didn't work lisa has something to
believe in
you know it has something to bank on or
to just for that moment man
to take me out of that despair the
desperation the [ __ ] and everything
else that came with the
the lifestyle of a crackhead of a
cocaine at it
and um
i'm not out the neck of the woods it's
not over not by far
i wish it was but it's not it's just
putting one foot in front of the other
man doing the best i can with what i'm
working with
and um i'll tell you one thing
i'll never give up on me no matter what
happens when it's all said and done when
the smoke clears and all that [ __ ]
i'ma still keep putting one foot in
front of the other one for what i know
going for broke man because it's all i
know
i wouldn't want it any other
[ __ ] way thank you
you